悟るっていう言葉についても結構質問が来てたんですけど悟りこれはどういう解釈をされてるの?悟りっていうのはね、心理が分かると見たらええかな。心理とは何かということがあるんよ。仏教とか授教が価だぞいのはあの
人とも心理に到達しとるんや。お釈迦も講師もで心理に
到達した後でその達する方法というのを残しておいてく。自分でやれということやね。
だから心理教えてもらうもんやなしにそこ
に到達して身につけるもんね。それが悟る
ということで全部考えることは正しい。
知ってることも正しい。全て正しくなる。
例えば仏教だと如来。如来って言っても
ちょっと分からんけどもた型って言うんや
。ガタっていうのは豪インドヨーロッパ
語族やから英語とようにとるよね。ガタは
ねえわ。たという意味が立ったっていうの
はそのごとにあなたというの女王みたいな
もんやありのままにという風にその如とに
なった。何のごとになった?自然の如とな
んやここが問題ない。自然自分の精神の中
の自然というのは本能のことだ。本能は
自分で作ったもんやないからね。理性は
自分で作ったもんだから間違っとるんだ。
本能はもう最初からインプットされとる
もんだから。だから正しい。その本能で
持って40億円行き続けてきたわけ。そこ
まで行ったら悟った。完全に食うになった
状態。これで食うの意味もだんだん上がっ
てくるやないか。自然のままや
。夜の11時過ぎから連続のアニメやっ
とったわ。ビンランドサガ。サガっていう
のはあのバイキングの伝説やな。
ビンランドはねブドのランド。どっかに
ビンランドっていうのがあってそこ行くと
氷もない雪もない。ものがいっぱい見っ
とるというバイキングにとっては天国
みたいな土地やな。で、そういう連続の
アニメがあったわ。で、その時にね、
デンマークの王子が愛とは何かということ
でずっと悩むんよ。ある時なんか戦争を
やってて兵隊が1人自分の目の前で死ぬん
や。で、その時にパッとひらめくんや。
これが愛なんだよ。で、彼の到達した愛と
いうのはね、空と一緒ない。誰見てね、
びっくりしたな。漫画家か小説家か知らん
けど筋を書いたのがな、彼らは分かっとる
んや。暴が分かってないっていうのはあれ
明らかにくだ。明らかに愛な。あの漫画を
見てパッとそれが分かる人はおるかな?空
がどうのこうの言とんなならそれは分かる
はずや
。
校長のおっしゃる悟りっていうのと授教でいう公然前の木を収めた状態ってのは結構近いんですか?
公然の木をあれは不同心を動かさるのところにあるんやけどな。申しの前然の木をうから俺は万能なんだって
番強いんだって言っとるわけやろ。完璧に正しくなったって言っとる自分がね。
それが公前の機内だけど学者はそれがどう
しても薬戦というのはヨーロッパの精神論
に独されとるからない。理性が正しくて
本のが間違っとるというのがヨーロッパの
精神論だけどなぜかは聞ことないやろ。
そうなら習ったわな。理性的にやらねば
ならなぜならば理性は正しい本能は間違っ
とるからである。どうしてそこがいるわね
。なぜ理性が正しいんや。なぜ本音が
間違っとるんや。それは教えてもらわん
やったろ。先生も知らんからな。だから
真面目な人はノイローじゃなっちまうわね
。精神家の薬のマといけないようになっ
ちまう。おかしい、おかしいと思ってね。
で、おかしいと思ってもうお前がおかしい
んだと言われてまた悩むわな。これぐらい
系統だってものを考えんっていうのかな。
基本を考えんというのか。1番いかんのは
ええか。仏教は精神論やろ。精神論なのに
リ廻転象が肉体論になっとるやないか。
おかしいと思わんか。肉体さえ
生まれ変わっていきゃええでリ廻から
逃れるのがええ言ったらもうそこで完璧に
死んじまうのがええってことになるもんね
。おかしいよね
。あるいはね、こういうのがあった前うち
に先輩がやってきてな、だいぶ先輩だ。
電話かかってきて久しぶりだね。行っても
ええかもんでどうぞ来てください。
ちょっと1人連れてくけど。は自分の子供
や。子供がおかしいんやね。来てみたら
やっぱり問題の体つき問題の顔しとるんや
ね。口が飛んがってもばっかり言うタイプ
ね。偉そうに偏差タイプやね。その
お父さんはもうこんなもん一生ダメだと
思うもんでなんとか言ったってくれ言っ
とるんや。本人は言われたくないわけやな
。どうせ自分が馬鹿にされるから。ほれで
あんた方に言われる覚えはない。これで
いいと思ってやっとるんだけど。ほう。
どうしての私の尊敬する偉い暴さに聞いた
んやと。人生は前世、元世、来世なくとも
その3つがあるんや。で、元世っていうの
は仮の姿である。来世が本ちゃんであって
それが非常に長く続くと。で、しかもその
元世がダメでもライスはうまくいくんや。
だから私は今努力してどうのこうのし
なんて全く思わない。来になるまで待っ
とりゃええんだから。お前今嫌やないか。
人に文句ばっかり言われて変な目で見られ
てね。女の子には持てんやろ。嫌やないか
いたらこれは今嫌だよっては死んだらどう
やね。ライスがええんやろ。は死んやええ
やないか。そんなひどいこと言うないもん
に何がひどいんや。ええこと言ってやっ
とるんやないか。親がびっくりしてやめて
くれ。坊主がこんなことによって金稼い
とるんや。いかんやろ。もうみんなね大腸
仏教だからそういうことになるんや。
みんなわしがええ方向に持っていってやろ
な。幸せにしてやるという。これが大丈夫
仏教やろ。こっから解放してやる。できる
わけない。お釈迦様は自分でやれって言っ
とるんだけど、自分でやる以外に方法がな
いっていうのが仏教やね。最初の仏教。
あれは教えであって宗教じゃないから。
教えていうのは儲からんからね。宗教にし
て儲けたんや。だから途中から宗教に
変わっちまって。で、今みたいに宗教だと
どうしても神様が欲しいわね。絶対風のだ
から来も欲しい。来というあるかない。
まずないわね。それで儲けるんだから。だ
しても宗教は詐欺になっちゃうわな。ない
ものを売っとるんや。
お坊さんは何で仏教を勉強してるんですか?
お坊さんは今までの伝統の本を読んで勉強しとるんやろうな。
大仏教の本。
大腸仏教ばっかりや。症状仏教の方が正しいと言っとる団体もあるよね。そっちの方が正しい。原始仏教が正しい。仏教を作った人が言っとることやからね。何よりも重要視線といかんのはお釈迦様の言っとることは価であるということや。だからそれをよく意味が分かって理解できねえ。仏教を理解したことにはならんわな。
こうしたらこうなるよって言っとるんだ
から。やってみらええやないか。実際そう
なるから。で、特に少年日本は仏教って
言ったら座然で座るあれが仏教やと思っ
症状。症状というのは少年を行うために
症状ができんとダメなんだ。方法
論少年それがよくわからんと。
[音楽]